hey thanks for tuning in to another
episode I'll have to be talk it is sep
tember 28 on monday and this episode is
brought to you by my incredible sponsor
earthquaker devices they've been a
sponsor for almost two years now they
are badass love them if you play guitar
bass funk jazz soul heavy metal any kind
of music style or instrument you're
going to need a stomp box a foot pedal
earthquaker devices makes the best
pedals on the planet handmade in Akron
Ohio you love it don't you you need to
sound like we rock gods get yourself a
delay delay delay or maybe some reverb
get a foot pedal overdrive so you can
sound all metal you know hmmm overdrive
they also got some badass shirts they
got one with this go octopus on it skull
octopus hit him up man I also tell them
that you heard this hat on let there be
talk and they'll give you a good deal
get yourself some modulation compression
octaves all that stuff is it sound weird
to you that's because you know play an
instrument get one anyway and put it
around your house it looks cool like a
like a like a painting or something some
art around your house support them their
support in the show thank you
earthquaker devices alright let's get
into the episode of fantastic guest
today a kind of a new friend who I met
at the Jackie Greene concert everyone
knows him if you watch conan o'brien he
is the leader of the basic cable ban
jimmy vivino he is awesome man this guy
knows music like you cannot believe we
talked for almost two hours and we could
have easily gone four or five hours I
mean it was a straight up like tennis
match just back and forth what a great
dude real deal he's played with some of
the biggest and the coolest people ever
played with levon helm's from the band
are you kidding me who plays with levon
Helm for the band you know he also
played with the Fagen from [ __ ]
Steely Dan I mean come on he's been with
Conan since 1993 what a great job man
you play guitar for a living and your
arm one of the coolest TV shows there is
so double home run ah I'm going to get
them on here before I do just a few
rundowns of what's going on with me I'm
up and moving around I'm feeling way
better everything's good the cuts are
all healed up ribs are still [ __ ]
that's it I wake up in the morning some
pretty serious ribcage brutality but
other than that I shake it off and I hit
the stage I hit the stage I was at La
Jolla all week and it felt fantastic to
be at the Millea Comedy Store back on
stage I was headlining did for shows if
you were at that show thank you so much
for coming out what an amazing audiences
all weekend everyone was great and Lucas
hurl my boys and BB combs brenton Biddle
combs they opened a featured the show
and it was just fantastic met a lot of
del razors that came out that was cool a
lot of people my boy Greg from the
Harley detour down there what's the name
of that dealers [ __ ] I forget the name
of it I better look it up real quick cuz
this so cool el cajon Harley el cajon
those guys man a whole crew from that
dealer came out felt great you know it
was really cool just have a lot of good
friends come out to the shows if you
want to see me this week I am going to
be home finally for a weekend here in
Los Angeles I will be Friday night let's
see what i'm doing friday if you live in
hollywood i'll be at the Laugh Factory
at midnight
also saturday i'm doing a very cool show
if you live out kind of the Thousand
Oaks or if you don't take a trip out to
the canyon club I'm up there with Spicer
and Bryan Callen canyon club is really
cool it's like a like some big rich guys
massive living room or something come
out and see that 8pm Canyon cup me Bryan
Callen and Spicer that's going to be a
good time and you know tonight I'm going
to see ACDC so I'm pretty [ __ ] up
glad to be alive it's good to be lame I
thank everyone for all your emails again
like I said I'm getting better I'm up
and running and it feels good also make
sure you go to marc maron's twitter or
his Instagram and wish him a happy
birthday his birthday was yesterday and
just bombard him with some love will you
also if you're out there in the out and
about bilborough's on tour go see Bill
he's out and about i don't know where
he's at but look it up i know he's on
tour and I guess that's about it short
intro today I'm just glad to share this
episode with E itself was so [ __ ]
good ok here we go light the candles all
right here we are another episode I'll
have to be talk fantastic guests
introduce yourself Jimmy Vivino and this
is so [ __ ] ghetto it's great no way
this is protein no dude yeah this is
like home no I feel like [ __ ] Wayne's
World well I if I bring people to the
studio nine [ __ ] the studio yeah I
always feel like they don't give me the
good [ __ ] at the studio hey can we say
[ __ ] anything you want right yeah yeah I
wouldn't see all this all these led
zeppelin pictures and [ __ ] man and yea
well you have no idea it's like a museum
that's a rock shop cool she yeah yeah
you were rock and roll comedian I guess
yeah yeah man well I played rock for 25
years I did music and had records out
and stuff yeah and then got smart and
got out
it's it's a two-way street really a lot
of my comic friends are musicians to and
really good ones yeah that better than
guys like me trying to go and stand up
yeah I mean yes that's the hardest job
is playing by yourself to playing with
yourself is easy but playing by yourself
is [ __ ] hard you know what's funny is
the last tour I did was with the
wallflowers and I did solo acoustic for
10 months and you're right it's so
nerve-wracking but somewhere along the
way on the tour I learned oh [ __ ] man i
was kind of turning it into one of those
vh1 storytellers well yeah and then I
started realizing in the back of my head
I'm gonna get ready for comedy yeah but
at least you have a guitar between you
in the audience yeah it's like a safety
net or a pillow it really is he [ __ ]
grabbing but you know the best I learned
from guys like Dion DiMucci you know
he'll come out with just his guitar and
Phoebe Snow and Al Kooper and they all
people that I worked with that were
storytellers yeah you know without I got
to the point where people say play a
song yeah I telling these great stories
from 1956 up until you know through the
60s and 70s and and it's like an
education and he's funny too so oh man
he introduced me to robert schimmel that
were friends yep and and Allan Havey all
these guys used to open up for us Wow
comedians it was Al Kooper that super
sessions record could be one of the
greatest records ever made yeah and it
was just a you know the idea was to jam
which was on you know was it wasn't done
before he went to Columbia and said
we're just gonna jam yeah and they said
yes they've made that record I really
feel like that's a certain era in a
music freaks life where it's this kind
of right of past someone turns you on to
it yeah and then all of a sudden you're
like oh man you feel like you're some
music guru the next level up you know
you're like have you heard this super
session to play from that record no vote
organ and guitar because it was that we
had this old hi-fi and
one side worked and you could switch
which side you wanted to hear you know
the wire so Bloomfield was on one side
and Cooper was on the other right so I
would practice my organ with the
bloomfield side turned on i practice my
guitar with else I'd turn I meet was
split it was panned like that hand left
right man wow I never noticed ace in the
middle I just got like a fifty-dollar
copy of it original mouth yeah he put
that on and it's just like oh my god
it's it's the tone the tone of the whole
record is great Harvey ended up being a
friend that record was really a lynchpin
and and my deciding to be in music
highway 61 record oh yeah well that's
crazy cuz you end up playing without
Cooper yeah it's not weird I meet a lot
of people and they're like oh this guy
was a story of my life looking over the
fence and saying pick me yeah pick me
out getting in the game you know being
11 or 12 and 13 going to the film ward
there was no way it was going to play
with these guys were as old as 19 and 20
yeah all these guys were now said amore
doesn't mean anything no Maurice more
East yeah all right ever went to the
fillmore west now let's get let's get
into this we met at Jackie Greene yeah
of course you play guitar and Conan's
Conan's a late night band that basic
came and 22 years unfucking believable
and and I what I really enjoyed was here
I was at the troubadour watching Jackie
Greene and you come in we meet a
fantastic cool guy and then you go on
stage and you proceeded to just crush it
you played b 3 yeah I prayed some lead
guitar I awesome piano well Jackie and I
are kindred spirits he said he's like my
son almost yeah so young you know but uh
well I stole the story I think somewhere
maybe at the gig that Jackie called me
when they were coming on the conan show
way back in New York and so do you play
banjo and I said yeah man and I hung up
the phone said I got to get a [ __ ]
badge up I figured I could do it and
learn their from Tommy tadesco he said
take the gig then figure out how to do
it yeah yeah because the guy asking you
doesn't do it yeah so you can figure it
out you know you play battle like ashore
go by a battle like a stick three guitar
strings
on it that sounds like a bow like I
think you can do that with everything
but pedal steel you know you are and not
make-believe a pedal you can't do you
can't know that that said that is
another thing man that's like you know
that's like driving a Ferrari or so it's
unbelievable got to have everything
going at once yeah and that I mean and
and pedal steel is of course you hear it
and it's big what sounds great though
y'all be in tune with you and you got to
know how the [ __ ] to do it not just be
cliche you know so Jackie you know jet
back to Jackie he was and then I ran
into him after that he was playing with
uh I guess with Phil Phil Phil yeah yeah
I was playing with levon and we were
opening up for them unbelievable you
know was like ah Jimmy B I'm gonna go up
and play with jam with them come up with
me so we went up in me and Jackie were
switching on guitar and piano and organ
you know so then we knew that we kind of
did the same thing so whenever he comes
around I tried to hang out and I was
surprised um you know I went to the
Grammy Museum to see his right he's a
night before I before and then he said
yeah we're I didn't know cuz I don't you
know I don't when I used to get the LA
Weekly or the village voice I would know
what's going on but I don't know where
the [ __ ] to look for anything anymore
yeah right it's just kind of online it's
like it's a it's a chore to find out
where music is yeah you know what I do
is I sign up for alerts yeah yeah I just
like you can put in like kind of stuff
you're in do and then it kind of sends
it to you like Oh Jackie grains playing
oh cool I have to check into that
because it sucks to look up your right
man and it's just kind of I always hear
about [ __ ] the next day now cuz you're
busy man well they list all the [ __ ]
first that you don't want to see ya and
you had a really go down and look where
is this happening in echo park or where
the [ __ ] is happening you know but you
can't find it right away where it used
to jump out of an ad yeah twitter is
great for this they have twitter i know
you're just getting all right now i
watched and see when people who said
that's how i got hooked up with devon
allman and some other people that were
coming in yeah yeah I find that out are
the men you usually the music's good
there any night yeah now how do you get
into guitar you grew up in Jersey right
yes cuz guy yeah I was a trumpet player
Wow there was a trumpet player III told
of this story before but my
parents my father was an immigrant from
Italy and they were all carpenters Wow
no one there was a it was him and his
brother and his brother-in-law my
grandfather the four of them had a
construction company and they were
building houses up and down the Jersey
Shore Wow just working you know and and
to have three sons like my father did
and have like you know Floyd and Jerry
and me all going to show business you
know yeah it was incredible let us Wow
yeah right instruction Empire you know
he could just smacked us in the head and
said which was standard practice by that
in those days kids yeah we didn't think
of anything when my father went for his
fork and I would flinch you know yeah
but that's the way it was old school dad
old-school Irish an Italian you know and
never said they loved you Yeah right ya
know you knew it though yeah yeah oh
yeah because after they after my father
would beat us up he come and apologize
you know why I beat your ass you know
why right cool now all right right I
didn't mean it you know you know he
never heard us though and and and and
growing up they had to be a certain
amount of fear for respect along with to
the police and teachers and parents and
you didn't want to get in trouble yeah
it's true I'm sewing up a kid I didn't
want to bum my mom out either yeah it's
kind of weird like like you know like I
would do drugs and stuff but boy would I
hide it you know yeah I just feel weird
about him my father would say to me what
are you on son don't think you haven't
tried anything that I didn't try and I
was like acid in 1940's yet I didn't but
I'm thinking that I'm not yeah
absolutely thinking that you know I'm
coming down yeah nice i'm coming down i
havena you know look in the refrigerator
find some meatballs and I'm fine yeah
but so so he let us all be in show
business you know but if we were gonna
do that we had to have I was like nine
we started a dance team we had to sing
dance play instruments we were you know
went to Tony grants cavalcade of stars
in Atlantic City yeah dance at the
World's Fair in 1964 in the Jersey
pavilion Wow we were kind of like the
Osmonds and what kind of dancing oh it
was jazz and tap tap dance yeah that's
it in playing music at the same time you
know I well being and doing doing marks
this bits you know now really what is it
is it because I know you're playing a
Beatles cover band was it the Beatles
that th yeah yeah probably yeah did you
see the ad Sullivan yeah i did and i
remember having to sit through Lawrence
Welk first wow you know yeah with all
your you know all the grandmothers and
GU modest and boom bothers everybody
that the aunts and uncles and and you
know and they're like oh watching work
Lawrence Welk and how nice and we were
playing trumpets and clarinets an
accordion yeah three of us so that was
like the music and then this thing
happened you know that that did you know
it was going to have no i didn't know we
watched that Sullivan no matter what r I
was law it was religion it was part of
every Sunday yeah we didn't say oh
that's on we're not going to watch it
same with Bonanza you watched it yeah
run you what I remember once well
because i would spend sundays at my
grandmother's grandfather's house and
they watch that [ __ ] man was it [ __ ]
drunk yep all those guys were like
master musician oh yeah i mean there was
some incredible technicians going on
there yeah but it was totally you know
for polkas and it was old world rise old
world yeah but it was that was the drunk
where the line was drawn you know when
the Beatles came on yeah they were like
oh my God look how funny they look and I
kind of funny they sound so you're on
the couch and then he slaughters the
woman the couch and then he says her on
the floor he's like ladies and gentlemen
Beatles and you're like oh what's this
screaming and why and you know and the
funny thing is I hadn't known an aunt
that was a little older and you know she
was a big d on and frankie valli fan and
Elvis fan yeah a lot of great music
fifties most of it Italian grease back
hair music yeah and doo-wop music like
what's that uh Broadway show called
where it's all the 50s guys oh well well
I mean there was a big one that it's
been going on forever it's quite a few
besides Greece which is a fake yeah not
Greece but the one that goes on now it's
like about the Jersey so there's a
Jersey boy yeah yeah that's it jersey
boys that's a frankie valli and a ford
edge yeah yeah of course that I just
digress because we just we get all over
the map because me and my brother played
with those got all those guys Wow all
those go Wow now what's your brother
play my brothers saxophone player
brother Floyd is a piano player and had
his own
own you know comedy show on TV in New
Jersey on the uncle Floyd show it's like
a big cult thing in the in the 70s and
80s and he had a kiddie show for adults
for people getting stoned you know Wow
and but you know all the punks came on
The Ramones Bowie no surety everybody
came on that show you know Cindy Lauper
at the time my member marshall crenshaw
the Ramones the smithereens smithereens
I've had blood and roses yeah Pat you
know Pat dionisio they were they own
garbage trucks in Newark don't know [ __ ]
so we knew pee pad as the greatest same
hey Jimmy who's better than us yeah as
we came out of that jersey thing anyway
so your brother has this variety show I
went it on once a week it was on every
night every night at the uncle Floyd
sure you could look it up and then he
got [ __ ] crazy great bands on their
yeah yeah and did you go down and watch
all this [ __ ] all the time I met a lot
of people i'm still in touch with today
through that that's insane to think
about that because you're on do that
though we're on Conan though I mean
you've really been kind of on TV that's
all your life and then we went to NBC
after the Tom Snyder show went down
before Letterman went on yeah for like a
half a season uncle Floyd was on no she
put it up there and and you know what
what's funny is that you could my
brother could go and buy time you know
he could skota the pet store and say
give me a hundred bucks I'll put you on
the air this week why'd he go to 20
places get himself you know I don't know
20 grand or something together yeah
produce the show for whatever it costs
2,000 bucks maybe yeah his people pay
the cameramen rent everything but to
show on make a nice profit yeah then go
out as his own ad agency you know Wow
just rent time on cable when it was
really young kind of like early like
podcast and right sure it is like pot
yeah exactly that's where the real [ __ ]
comes out you're so right and that
Punk's realized it because they were so
sick of the corporate world anyway yeah
you know in all the network [ __ ] they
said look at this thing we found Wow and
then you know John Lennon would sit on
his couch up in the Dakota and watch the
uncle Floyd show and Bowie would watch
it and all these guys wanted to come on
they would lip-sync did linen
I know yeah right he was you thinkin
bread back yeah their lips in kind of
like American Bandstand it all happened
you know was so weird because at that
time we you know we'd go out and buy I
would buy Ramones records and stuff and
I would think wow these guys must be
doing great man they were they were
struggling Yeah right oh damn it to make
it and they were they were great band
you know yeah I met him on I think
around 81 or whatever and and they had a
part of town they're all staying in the
same room yeah oh yeah was like wait a
minute you guys have shitloads of
Records out of that Queens guys yeah
yeah you know yeah no but they but you
know safety in numbers to you know
because they were arrest no he'll
realize how they were harassing us and
they were rockin rollers they would not
Punk's they get work they were rocking
right we had Chrissie Hynde said to me
that said the other day she was on the
show Oh punk lasted six months yeah and
then all of a sudden the guitar players
said I think I learned how to play Yeah
Yeah right there like this X months it
was over the three chords got born and
turn into four chords yeah and leads
yeah man Qatar see how did you know yeah
so I mean in all this we you know we
grew up in the 60s late in the mid to
late 60s the explosion between 64 and 70
in those six years nothing can happen
for six years now just sits your dormant
music yeah in those six years we got all
really six or seven years we got all the
Beatle records yep right all of them
yeah all of 63 270 the beginning of 70
crazy it's like a seven-year period we
have that entire output and not to
mention what this is the way the stones
you know changed everything changed yeah
yeah stones brought us the blues The
Yardbirds Zeppelin that all happened in
a couple of years oh the whoo cream yeah
creamed all of that stuff it's insane
Hendrix and then they were playing three
at a time on a bill to fillmore for
three dollars fifty cents yeah yeah so
we did in our older brothers and their
older brothers she ever needs Milgram
yes yeah me too I was working with Laura
Nero and we played the Fillmore this was
a
in the late 80s I guess we played the
fillmore up in san francis yeah great
bill was there she said to me watch he's
just gotta pace back and forth through
the whole show yeah and he took me up in
the office where all his posters were
and everything and I just loved him he
was all may he's the reason I'm alive
yeah you know I mean because without
those shows and stuff I probably would
have just I mean I know I would have
went into some darkness you know what I
mean he it was a complete visionary have
you seen the thing at the Museum yet the
skirball discarded screwball yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah man I was in there I had
to go alone because I didn't want
anybody to rush me I could look at
photos for hours yeah you know because i
went to all most of those shows and not
the early sixties one but you know once
i'm up and running and I just stare at
I'm like well when you go to enough of
them you start remembering shows you
didn't go to yeah well you really do
because we'd exchange this you know yeah
and it becomes part of our history yeah
and then it becomes real to us even the
things we didn't do become so real
because it was such a magical time man
yeah it really was right a little extra
help you know we had a great time haha
so all of that was happening and i was
playing trumpet man I said man I gotta
start i got myself before fiza organ and
started playing organ oh yeah you know
when I was like well it'd be 12 times
that I think the doors or you just or
yeah right it was the doors it was it
was Steve Winwood uh-huh you know and it
was Felix Cavaliere with her ass oh yeah
yeah the things ray manzarek was God you
know and then I course digging everyone
in that band that was probably when I
was uh you know starting bands the most
important band yeah because their stuff
was accessible in the way you could play
it I love the cloud really sing it yeah
right right yeah that clavinet has got
to be the best sound I was Stevie Wonder
coming with that thing that thing is so
great it's like pom pom pom pom pom pom
what a sad Star Force TV you know and
when that happened that was like 70 you
know that started happening yeah he want
a clavinet yeah yeah one when what are
talking book came out my friends brought
it down we were listening to you know a
lot of a lot a lot of different music
and then that came yeah
was a young boy yeah then he opened from
stones that was crazy on a 72 tour
whatever there are 7 5 11 at time and
then I switched the guitar when I was
like 22 23 what makes you switch to
guitar Oh carrying the [ __ ] be three
and yeah rights my brother owned and he
was a sax player used to yell at me how
come I have the van yeah you've got to
leslie's and a beat three and a Fender
Rhodes and a clavinet an ARP synthesizer
and I got a one saxophone playing on the
good were you going where you put gone
for like some of that uh you know like
faces or was it more deep purple where
he getting into the kind of disorder
cool deep well it was distorted because
the tubes were all but I had vowed
exactly deep purple gets that we can go
into we could talk about me a bit more
and then I want to get into some of this
[ __ ] you got because you know then I
switch the guitar and you know I mean I
i I've started hiding in a show band you
know yeah I show band was something that
was like a Martin and Lewis had a
comedian Bobby DeAndre and a singer
Frankie Sorrell and then you had a
four-piece band behind him yeah you
played all the goomba joints in New
Jersey yeah all of them and just making
money all of them all the leisure suits
and people cheating on their wives yeah
I'm making money and playing your guitar
every day some mob [ __ ] around there you
seen that I I'm not saying don't be
alive like the week before yeah Vincent
and Pesci would be in before us yeah Joe
was the guitar player yeah great guitar
play funny compassion man yeah and
Frankie Vincent who he kills in every
movie was his buddy oh you know and
you've seen Frankie he's bit he's Billy
bang he's a guy they stabbed in the back
of the trunk mom yet knife and the foot
know what do you call we got caught in
the grill yeah yeah yeah and and also in
in Raging Bull he smacks his head in a
car door oh that's my favorite yeah he
just like destroys him at the top three
film of all time for me yeah that's
right that's great right here you know
it's a great story I'm Pesci where he
[ __ ] gives up he's just done and he's
a waiter in some restaurant and Scorsese
sees them and says like hey I saw you in
something man what are you doing now is
that guy [ __ ] quit yeah
I got something for you and it's [ __ ]
Raging Bull and then that Vicky Vicky
never did any film well she opened a
mulberry street pizza though and wow
yeah yeah but you know just so those
guys were guitar players and singers too
and and and Joey also was was the band
boy for the four seasons and that's
documented you know Joe Pesci was there
was their roadie Wow much when he was a
kid my first guitar well I got I was you
know was sitting in the basements my
uncle's harmony oh wow yeah like the
semi hollow body just yell like a semi
whole body f hold cheap harmon kind of
like a like a like it did have a single
cutaway no cutaway at all our holes it
had that fake painted on oh yeah
tiger-stripe everyone curtains moya look
like yeah my buddy had one of those in
harmony I don't know what it was called
but it and it was great this is like
silvertone and all those silvertones
harmony Stella's all of them yeah and
and and that was in the basement I used
to mess around with that and I remember
learning bass lines on it yeah not being
I'm not knowing what notes i was playing
even but digging the feel of it in my
hands yeah and then messing around with
some tunings and I could play a couple
cowboy chords but never really serious
so I had that for a long time I think I
may still have it in fact Wow and and my
uncle left it you know when he was like
moving out or something he left it some
[ __ ] in the basement including that
guitar Wow and I've always went down in
the bait the basement was my place where
that that [ __ ] up stereo wasn't only
once i worked on ya and ya guitar was
down there a trumpet there was you know
I had my my hohner pianet down there and
yeah farfisa you know and I just
practiced in practice in practice you
remember the amp you had yeah he'll j'en
he was made in New Jersey I he'll jhil
GE and somebody out there knows what it
is Wow one day though the poor Hill j'en
it was it was a 212 cabinet and ahead
yeah and it was probably about 30 watts
one day that the fuse blew so he took a
piece of oh man I'm that old one and
trying to get in there oh boy it sounded
great for about ten minutes
thick white smoke yeah out of it yeah it
turned yellow that was the end of the
hills and I must say we burned to the
ground they think it was hand wired man
back the problem yet it was a great
point to point to point song just like
those silver tongue yeah yeah and I got
one of those from a friend Wow
silvertones yeah yeah yeah so yeah we
always had stuff we borrowed stuff you
know we would say hey we call the guy
down shooter you doing anything can I
borrow your trainer amp in or can we
borrow the PA trainer that's a great
manner was a great buddy world it for
bass rig for gyros trainer yba ones you
could turn into little marshals it's
crazy right yeah anyway so rock and roll
was it man I never you know and I I did
okay in school and all that but I just
wanted to play music yeah I mean I knew
from when I was nine like you say that I
just and and my father made me work some
construction just so I wouldn't want to
do it yeah you know yeah I won't even
buy direct access you wanted you want to
bust your ass out here what you want to
practice your instrument and get a job
you know so soon as I finish high school
me and my brother started a band and
work seven nights a week Wow up and down
the Jersey coast I mean there was work
then yeah so we learned everything just
working you know and what are you
playing fifties covers oh we're playing
we're playing stuff from the 60s of
course some 50s we're backing up the
five satins and Jackie Wilson and all
these people coming into you know we
used to place it at this lounge for like
six months at a time up in Wayne New
pequannock New Jersey up way up way up
there towards Valley you know towards
the Playboy Club in Gregor yeah yeah
yeah and and and they would bring in
Chubby Checker they would bring in
Jackie Wilson bring in the platters so
you were the back of man we'd back up
all these guys yeah like I saw Chuck
Berry he just pulled up in the car in
the band there was a band they hired and
yes they suck I played with him many
times and the one thing I do know is I
wake up every day yeah and forgive Chuck
Berry oh yeah yeah yeah music says it
doesn't matter how you can meet somebody
on their worst day and the wrong opinion
of him yeah you know and I'm still
waiting for that good day from chuck i
saw i saw him yelling at the bed to you
talking no he went through hell and he's
still one of the greatest songwriters
yeah oh yes it goes directly from him
the dill
if you think about it yeah really does
you know subterranean homesick blues
that's that's uh you know that's
Maybelline you know yeah yeah it is as I
was motivating over motor cool down no
that that's that role is what Bob was
bob was into that too many apophysis
insane you know it's insane about bob is
there's just all these different eras
well there's no comparison there are no
one can compare to him like like you'll
be like oh man I'm way into the desire
record yeah yeah and they're like oh
well that one got [ __ ] on earlier yeah I
just one of that yeah no it's fine it's
all great only the only only the the
critics were bad yeah it's true yeah
it's true the critics never come back
like they [ __ ] on Zeppelin on every
record you know they never came back
late yeah we were all Frank Zappa said
that writing about music is like dancing
about architecture yeah stupid it's
stupid to write about what somebody
wrote yeah music or are you gonna be I
don't know I mean we've all been through
it with reviewers most of them don't do
anything ya know if you know other comic
does a review on you yeah I'd say Oh
simunition says but somebody who can't
play or sing or write we have new comedy
or you know and everything ever that
critic campaign well everything's
personal taste too yeah you know and
also I'll tell you what there's many
albums over there that when i first got
him i went [ __ ] dis record and then
traded it you know yeah one of them
being achtung baby I remember it came
out that's like oh this records horrible
and then a year later my mind's ready
for it same with Bruce Springsteen know
when I heard a wild and innocent or
maybe the first one wild an incense one
of my favorites and I said oh this guy's
just doin Van Morrison yeah you know and
and yes he was but yeah just doing that
more yeah right was he was taking that
next step with it yeah you know we like
to be closed-minded as kids and hey I
like Van Morrison nothing's better than
man more that's exactly our problem yeah
better or not we don't we not open we
don't have in our heads to oh this guy
likes Van Morrison to and listen where
he took that yeah that were like no it
ends here yeah like I love the Grateful
Dead now I'm obsessed with him I grew up
in San Francisco and I would always be
like [ __ ] those hippies man
[ __ ] sucks well we're all we're all like
Jack Black and high fidelity yeah you
know i'm not selling you that record cuz
it sucks yeah yeah yeah it's funny
though it must be so weird to be a
reviewer and later maybe the guy likes
the record and he has to admit it like
you know I was wrong there but they
never you never read the follow-up you
know I think maybe Jon Landau has said
he was wrong about certain things yeah
yeah you know he single-handedly broke
up cream well I given them this horrible
review and and it's just like depress
the hell out of them you know and and
you know the Beatles at the same time
everybody was was took you know Beatles
and cream all the English bands took it
to a certain point yeah then the band
came oh man you know with Bob Dylan it's
and it changed everything all of a
sudden tumbleweed connection comes out
yeah Elton trying to write his band
album yeah Delaney and Bonnie and and
this stuff comes out and and Eric and
Georgia like I want to be in in those
bands yeah cuz I want to be in the band
and filled and and so was about now
Americanizing uh the English sound yeah
you know through they did it enough with
what Dylan was doing you hear it really
happened on on basement tapes but yeah
but after but you here and having pink
after that on the stones a beggar's
banquet oh yeah a lot of Dylan coming
out of absolutely no absolute then it
starts getting like oh it's about
serving the song cream Clapton was like
oh it's not about me just wanking back
here because cream was like a jazz band
yeah they were no a jazz the jazz thing
miles and Coltrane and Parker was to
play the head and then go off in the
middle and just jam your asses off and
then come back and play the head exact
formula of what cream did yeah and then
Clapton started getting like I think I
want to play songs you know yeah JJ cale
he's writing to and it was changing you
know was changing it was because of that
gun as far as it could really what was
it you played with levon Helm what era
did you play with him well the rambles
we started doing those and God I don't
remember what year I know I was living
down the road from him Wow and we had
met at Chicago blues festival i was with
johnny johnson playing
and an mic merit and James warm earth
who are in the band with me now at Conan
and and the band the band's bus pulls up
and uh and he saw the band yeah yeah
they pick us up you know and and at that
time it was already I saw the band way
back in the 70s Wow but at this point
well I mean that was you had to the band
in the dead at Roosevelt Island you know
now Wow and Watkins Glen which was a
great trip you know yeah almonds dead in
the band yeah just insane and and then
the later versions when after Robbie had
left I would Richard and Rick and leave
on guard still and what was that car
with dango it was still bad and of
course it was all the voices were there
and Jack wieder was a great guitar
player is so I met them in Chicago at
the Blues Festival and then we got to be
friends you know and um you know Levon
just was like a big brother to me you
know along with a lot of blues guys and
what a voice huh yeah the voice of
america is this guy rolled and yeah it's
just like it's just like you know what
its a math you babe Brady photograph
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like Civil War
you know it's like bang I listen to the
band and it really was turned on to the
band uh maybe 20 years ago from Jakob
Dylan cuz the wallflowers would play the
wait yeah you know and that's always
everybody's first introductory abduction
to the band is the wait yeah and I
listened to it and I still don't even
know how you could put together a band
that sounds like the band ah but they
worked they worked in Toronto up on
Bloor Street up there in young street
yeah they work with Ronnie Hawkins they
played like six shows that's right there
is back a bad day every day yeah and he
was a slave driver yeah that was crazy
they learned to do everything they
played every kind of music and they had
to play a lot of country music up there
but no one sounds like them it's just
you know that's the way the gods aligned
it you know them Godspell that way yeah
and and those voices danko is in maine
only the beatles had like three four
lead singers like that yep yeah and and
and they did you know they did too and
and Robbie's stories were gray
those guys were great storytellers yeah
so the combination of that writer with
those voices is uh you know it's like
you know what a writer having an acting
troupe ya know for his place yeah yeah
and that same troupe you know does it
and it's it's it's special that way they
groove man everything about it their
outfits the instruments they play
[ __ ] hipsters trying to look like you
know that yeah yeah sorry you know yeah
they dress my way cuz it was all they
can afford yeah yeah so where is that
he's like I mean even when what was the
band Mumford & Sons yeah there for a
while they're just straight up looking
like the doors too yeah exactly yeah way
back uncle tupelo uncle tupelo of course
yeah yeah jeff tweedy and jay farrar man
those guys were into it too but they you
know that's you know that is that was
the beginning of this resurgence of
America yeah I love that [ __ ] the old
country yeah I mean when you got into
Wilco son volt yeah you got into the
early whiskeytown Ryan's first man it
was great and also the J Hong's justice
absolutely lone justice yeah man yeah
Shane in the jayhawks yeah uh you know
that all year the the who what was just
um the Bandit backed up Steve Earle
later it was was at the dead Steve Earle
Eberle yellow fever also was cinda
williams car wheels in a gravel road yet
all this was it go in them Eric Campbell
yeah yeah yeah what was that dough Lord
the dell war yeah yeah that was you know
yeah late 70s yeah there's some that
alt-country really came at the right
time man it was just like wow this is
[ __ ] it call it Americana now yeah
yeah yeah it didn't have a name yeah you
know Emmylou was doing it with the hot
band for years yeah yeah with albert lea
and all those guys seagulls flying
burrito brothers i mean thats Mach 1
yeah it was really retos man eagles the
burritos yeah and and of course in 1969
i went to the fillmore to see how Cooper
Wow and he didn't show up well I pissed
off man oh the birds are gonna play [ __ ]
you know was Procol Harum
the birds are like Raven you know the
birds how great is our birds we're gonna
headline after Procol Harum they were
gonna go up impossible yeah well they
come out it's not the birds that I
thought I was gonna see yes Clarence
white on guitar oh wow it's that bad
it's the sweethearts pain yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's yeah it's that you know it's
it's this guitar playing that was like
blowing my mind yeah we didn't know he
had this b bender thing Gideon I love
that thing yeah to be bitter and and
they were so heavy man they weren't like
the birds at all that I had seen it and
in 1966 out of high school in New Jersey
right different birds yeah I know the
crosby and sweetheart record is huge
yeah it's just fantastic old record
right what's being recorded and I think
they had a day off or something and they
played they came and they played the
fillmore for a night to fill in yeah so
it was it was mind-blowing how good it
was yeah and it was a playing situation
yeah you know so I blew my mind there
you go again I had a preformed you know
yep my of the birds was like I they're
just gonna sing Dylan songs in harmony
yeah yeah no now even that even saying
that sounds really stupid yeah because
they always are everything's great and I
just went back even their names cool
right it is and I just went back
recently got it all again along with the
Hollies now don't get any respect yeah
now going back to of course I you know
things you mentioned John Lord and deep
purple yep okay let's have let's start
picking the bones with the hands that
belong in the Rock and Roll Hall Oh God
way I mean this is purple it's
unbelievable they're not man rock'n'roll
Hall fancy garbage can any you go in and
store still today 40 years later I
treasure plain smoke on it's
unbelievable years the first song you
learn it's one finger damn yeah yeah
yeah I'm not to mention that the heinous
just like dissing of the mc5 who were
like in Detroit there's no I mean and
those guys are there's no punk or glam
rock without them you know it's weird
it's on it's the rock and roll hall of
fame and I've had an even Patti Smith
would admit yeah I here on the couch
before her and there's just they make no
sense at all you know what I made they
make no sense at all we can't blame
anybody that does get in for getting it
oh no I never do that i never i never
got you should be and not fair to say
that because they try to keep it vital
by having people's interest in some
newer people yeah yeah course that like
with hip-hop people like oh it should be
true that everybody should go and see ya
outta compton oh thats I say they you
know the Howlin wolf said said at the
end of an old record he said that people
say you don't like the blues but you
wrong yeah yeah yeah well I feel the
same way that that is a lot like hip-hop
well I was there if so it's Jane's
Addiction its guns and roses and that's
the [ __ ] huge thing and then the next
what I call heavy metal was NWA yeah
because it was dangerous yeah it had
complete outlaws in the band and in it
had a radical message and that's what
rock you know it's a great movie we
almost we almost forget that the guys
that that survived that are still out
there they went through a lot man I'm
not no really yeah you know it yeah man
it was you know it's funny because the
blues was a lot like that in Chicago
yeah guys were knife fights killing each
other hitting each other over the head
word but that [ __ ] was real gangsta [ __ ]
was real I mean it was like yeah you
know it was gay it was ghetto yeah and
it really the music was always coming
out of all this [ __ ] man and that's why
the blues and rock and roll is so as
such a violent side to it man yeah man I
I did a movie with icecube about seven
years ago and I just couldn't get over I
met a lot of stars in my life but I
couldn't get over like man that's
[ __ ] ice guy know like when I was a
kid that guy was just like and then you
find out on the movie he's writing all
the [ __ ] wraps for all of them yeah
really not a bad kid though Yuri about
you see that and their naps are [ __ ]
with him to have his books and throwing
them on the ground yeah just cheating my
chest a good kid really he's not a beast
not a gangster not at all man but he's
living amongst that yeah
and he's an observer yep so he's like a
UH is like a poet topical comic you know
yep somebody who's commenting on the
times and he's a poet yeah and uh Street
poet you know and and a really good guy
too and iced tea too yeah look at that
we had cop killer all that [ __ ] back in
there after them you know yeah yeah
alleys of me a media star you know but
you know what the choices die or adapt
that's it man oh that's it it's what you
can only it's also like when bands were
shooting junk in the 80s it's here or
even the grunge scene it's either yeah
you're shooting junk you're in this
whole scene but it's like all right
either quit or you die well how
different is that from Lenny Bruce room
that's it think about it exactly you
know the first one is always a tragic
one yeah and then the guys get smart
like George Carlin they still say what
Lenny was saying but they a little
smarter about yeah yeah the first guy
has to really stand up and yell about
what it is yeah then everybody else gets
the benefit people forget him they just
climb over like I'm gonna fall out and
that and that's what happens yeah
absolutely and it happens uh you know
with music it happens with actors you
know yeah it happens you know lately
again guys like Mitch Hedberg it happens
yeah it's like whoa and then you see
other guys and you say you know someone
will always come along that's unique
yeah and you can only hope that it won't
they won't be screwed up from it because
you know there's a certain amount of
today we're all men of letters ADHD yeah
OCD yeah you know all men of letters
yeah yeah now that some kid that might
be a genius comics gonna have that [ __ ]
beat out of them with drugs and yeah
they give them stuff you know like to
just level them out but you know the
anger is part of getting getting that
out you know and yeah if you take drugs
it takes away your your your insanity
which is mostly stuff that yet right you
know anyway it really does cuz then
you're flatlined and you have no feeling
or anything and you're like well what do
you feel about that it's like so good
Yeah Yeah Yeah right comedy when it's
all good unless you're Cheech and Chong
yeah and then
and that's a whole genre yeah that's a
whole genre but music is the same way to
you know they owe the Southern
California sound always got you know
maligned on the East Coast for just
being too cool you know yeah too perfect
yeah sunshine but when you live out here
like I have now for six years yeah i
understand it yeah i hear that music you
know oh hell yeah man we'd be like when
you watch the eagles documentary you
just have to look great you just
absolutely worship them you know it's
really great because they like hipsters
always try to [ __ ] on the Eagles when I
was growing up before they call them
hipsters aware guys would be like I'll
[ __ ] those guys man the burritos is
where it's at and I'm like really man
you're gonna deny all these [ __ ]
songs yeah all of them you're gonna
denies are you looking if you riding
your bike wouldn't you rather hear some
of that [ __ ] and I'm steppenwolf oh god
yeah yeah man oh man I love that what's
the song on on the steppenwolf one on
Easy Rider or who does it the one to
push your mad goddamn the pusher man
like that I played that with / at at the
Maori sugar mill cuz we were getting
songs together and and I said well how
about these oh yeah I used to play that
my first band well played pusher and
then we find out Hoyt Axton wrote it
right Wow place the father and gremlins
real also wrote also wrote Jeremiah was
oh yeah no no no no and he also wrote
the pusher and he have other really
great oh he also wrote will I never been
to Spain for you know wow you know [ __ ]
I got renmei accent I think it was his
mother or sorry wrote uh Heartbreak
Hotel Wow so they were like you know
that's a [ __ ] right here fam yeah
right right yet did you did you see
Allman Brothers at the Fillmore um yes
yeah and towards the end you know when
end of the film or not the end of the
omen right right right I join all Manila
Oh Duane was still there yes and the
next time I went to see the mad Wayne
had passed right and it was at Watkins
Glen yeah yeah yeah and Barry was still
there i believe and and no second guitar
player no
lavell I just come into the dough Chuck
Leavell yeah who's ya been in the stones
forever now yeah and and and just Dickie
was playing guitar then and I it's I've
gotten to be friends with those cats you
know and and their kids and oh yeah and
all of them who was knocking you out on
guitar back then well always Mike
bloomfield oh yeah always Duane always
Clapton always Johnny Winter duh you
know that's funny marin hates Clapton
yes I keep telling them you know Marin
hate the Beatles yeah he wouldn't talk
about the fab faux you know I had this
great beetle man man Willie have a
beetle man yeah yeah it is not a wigs
and suits and plastic noses not a wax
fruit bands yeah you know I saw the
beetle mania and it was it blew my mind
was a kid we don't do it I understand we
just play the music right and we take
the records in fact we're playing at
Northridge you know in October Wow 17th
I'm gonna play we're gonna play you know
we're gonna play music and and Marin's
like I don't want to talk about that cuz
I don't like the Beatles oh that's right
I forgot mark you like we're talking
about you man you feel it is what it's
his birthday today happy birthday and
he's like her he's like my best friend
and listen and listen I know when I went
over there and he took out a final copy
of the animals and he put it on his
thing yeah and it was mano yeah and it
sounded like we were in the [ __ ] room
with the animal that's cool round
telling her yeah it felt like it was
three dimensional I got a Marvin we
didn't even have a drink I go to his
house sometimes and he'll put on like we
were there one day and we turned up ACDC
power aid and we just sat on the couch
we and say anything and it was like Bon
Scott was [ __ ] in our yeah final you
listen yeah yeah of course in so many
ways like all I like to Kingston I like
to who yeah and I loved like you know
the yardbirds yeah yeah well that's
clapping no not really its page more you
know how when we get into that yeah he
always says to me he says you think you
think everything's amazing and like no
I'm only talking about stuff i think is
amazing well he's a really good guitar
player he is you know I'd tell him all
the time and then he likes hearing it
more even he is good though we got a
great vibrato we do that gentleman
sound like Clapton and he goes I don't
like Clapton I mean we do that jam at
the baked potato and he kills yeah and
we did a stray cat strut yeah hey just
rocks it man he can play I love we can
play ah so those are the guys let's talk
and you know of course page in back of
course horse yeah of course all of those
who get into Eddie were you into that
later we know what happened was right
around then right around the set that
part of the 70s I late 70s I started
getting really into like magic Sam and
you Burt summer all the Chicago guy oh
wow I started going back where went
backwards backwards and I wasn't hearing
that you know that shredding yeah you
know because I had been through that
loving Frank Zappa's playing and he was
the original shredder right right right
right really just like playing playing
playing playing you know and and and I
was enim and John McLaughlin I saw him
too you know but Peter Green theater
grander green was great but he's more
like a Chicago right right so when I
finally did I think maybe sometime in
the 90s I guess when Van Halen was
really big i vant Hagar yeah yeah yeah
no before that ball 84 yeah yeah jumping
all that jumping all the animal animals
great well that's the song that turned
me Wow cuz I heard that and I said
that's cool man that is really great you
know and and and then I started yet I
mean I got a lot of bands late man you
know uh I think I got this California
sound blade of chili peppers and yeah
you know Guns and Roses was easy because
it was just real rock and roll yeah so
there was nothing to listen through its
just oh it's coming again it's like you
know it was a great version of the
stones and Zeppelin time and Aerosmith
in aerospace I like that a lot of like
that and that was always great and that
was always like familiar territory yeah
there was nothing like a revolutionary
it was just again great rock and roll
and dangerous though again you know
because it was like oh [ __ ] well they
looked dangerous yeah anyway you know
and that was important yeah especially
with what was coming out of LA at the
time we think about poison and bad side
yeah yeah and the real the big hair band
whites
yeah and warrant yeah and all that kind
of I don't know who else was Detective
around and no he's [ __ ] band yeah all
those fans yeah you know uh really the
spill off for Motley Crue yeah yeah well
I through the top of the pyramid yeah
Motley Crue quiet right they kick open
the door and then I'll said it's just a
[ __ ] army of what what is this and
Quiet Riot gets off on playing Slade
covered yeah like I was a big Slade fan
yeah Mott the Hoople you know and I go
well they just you know they just
updated it it's just jared covered that
was weird right it is doing covers yeah
but they knew that how to get a club
crowd going nuts with those songs yeah
yeah so it was like a you know it wasn't
really a cheap shot it was a really
smart move absolutely absolutely and
they can Welsh people people that were
in the quiet riot didn't even know it's
late was ya know they didn't and ran you
know and that's an Noddy Holder late
they almost sound like a spinal tap band
when you read their names yeah it's like
that does a guy named Noddy Holder I was
one of my favorites menu and they all
made up names back then yeah all the
Mott the Hoople guys had fake names you
know so so that was you know I found out
later that that Ariel bender yeah who
came in after mick ralphs was really
Luther grows nur who was the guitar
player in spooky tooth years before the
spooky Jeff great band yeah yeah there's
so many great bands right well I don't
think you can really listen to
everything it's just so much well you
have to at least now I go back like you
do yeah hey that's better than I
remember that being oh god yeah right
like today I'm listen to Curtis Mayfield
I'll go yeah oh yeah don't listen to
Johnny paid string charts you know going
on man i learned to deconstruct those
records and learned how to range from
those records there was a time that this
there's times in my life where [ __ ] hits
me and I go oh well this is all I'm
listening to for now on you know yeah
and that was really Curtis Mayfield with
the cry baby you know that sound it's
like why won't you give me alone but the
falsetto vocal incredible Shey and out
if there's a hell below dancing that
yeah yeah I can't even sing the first
line
you know it's one and also pusher man we
can't sing that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know but man it's a dead guy he's
the first guy to use the n-word yeah pop
records yeah and get away with it was
funny I was playing it for a guy
yesterday and he's like oh man I mean
how many times does he say that because
it was the only one saying yeah yeah and
it was a blaxploitation film yeah yeah
now soundtrack for you know it meant
something different then too I saw him
at in Central Park Wow Curtis Mayfield
yeah they had he played in Central Park
right around the time when when that was
out you know in I don't know maybe it
was like 74 right 70 fry and I remember
them playing Freddie's dead like live
and it was so and it looked like there
was about 15 people on stage yeah and
Curtis all dressed in white huge white
bell-bottoms giant floppy hat he look
like one of the Cosby kids and then he
got [ __ ] man light rig fell on yeah
but he made a great record after that he
did what was the last record is really
great I don't know the name of it even
but somebody played it for me said dig
this and I said you bet you haven't
listened to this I said no yeah you know
yeah stop sometimes but there was a last
record and whatever it is it's worth
getting cuz yeah yeah yeah yeah he could
sink still yeah I got the box set just
recently it's up there I'm gonna dig in
and it's like everything get all of that
depression yeah exactly exactly man that
stuff's like I remember I got the record
i called this is my country by that that
i love so much and it was just a total
blackness record it had white people
didn't even know it existed yeah it's
just they're standing in the rubble of a
ghetto on the cover of it Wow and it's
just total social comment Wow no end and
not what you know not what white people
were listening to it all and yes man he
was very very out I mean he it's amazing
that he didn't get like assassinated
yeah right yeah [ __ ] he was saying on
record yeah got early on guys that were
they had a point of view yeah it was
point of view you know it's even like
early public enemy is some of my
favorite Chuck D he picks it up and just
like telling you what's going on in the
neighborhood fight the power well
and Marvin Gaye was yeah yeah what's
going on because that and and mercy
mercy me about the ecology yeah you know
it was like wow you're gonna say this is
gonna get out and say this those guys
are so badass man I love above well
Marvin and Stevie both rebelled against
the system yeah Motown yep and that's
why Tamela was started Wow because
that's you know that's Marvin started
Tamela you know so him and Stevie could
make their music away from the corporate
machine the machine hit-making yeah yeah
that's when those records what's going
on and music of my mind yeah yeah yeah
Stevie but before talking book music of
my mind came out yeah when they
controlled their careers and went in and
made their own records it's a museum so
right like songs in the key life I mean
that stuff all those records use doing I
think he's like what 15 16 when he's
doing that stuff early on the stuff and
earth wind and fire oh it's earth wind
fire absolutely blows my mind and there
was all these bands back then they had
lakeside you know all these like uh they
were just like it was pretty Beverly and
maze were great yep pre disco yeah well
it's funk yeah it's fun it's but it was
it was it was gone down but it wasn't
part when was in charge of Ellen yeah
was it wasn't James Brown yeah right
exactly it was just like yes you know
because Maurice White yeah was a jazz
drummer and he played in ramsey lewis
band yeah and and those guys were all
you know they had a chord jazz chord
structure in their writing yeah you know
this beautiful stuff that they're doing
but it's still grooving like crazy you
know and that's you don't you we don't
get that anymore somehow it's coming
back a Raphael Saadiq yeah does it a lot
of Curtis sort of stuff and if you dig
Raphael it's coming back in a way but
it's very niche and Harry retro yep you
know what josh Stone doesn't him and of
course Justin I mean you know and also
st and trucks are doing great things
yeah that are more like Delaney and
Bonnie you know there's but again my
heart always goes to stuff that reminds
me of exactly certains you know so
what's new is the question yeah yeah
yeah I mean what is new you know like
once in a while something will hit me
and I back wow wow that's it's pretty
you know I mean I'm still I'm still
loving kraftwerk and nobody's hehe like
way back then all the way from this
still out playing you know there's a new
dead weather coming which I came out on
friday it's fantastic i had Allison on
the show a couple weeks ago that record
is fire yeah and everything all new dead
weather i think know everything jack
white does is is in a maze of jack uh
jack besides being a Batman villain in
real life yeah is a cat that knows what
a riff is yeah you know and there's
nothing that gets us going like a good
riff that's what it is every one of us
and Jack you know he's the rift King man
he knows about writing a rift and and
you know it doesn't matter you know it
doesn't matter who he's playing with ya
what really steals that movie with the
three it may get loud with your age and
and the edge yeah the opening scene he's
building a guitar yeah and the mystique
of that whole thing you know and they
just plugs it in it's like you know he
is he's from Detroit yeah you know
that's important too don't forget that's
where rock and roll really you know
really comes a lot of it really comes
from Motor City yeah the dirty rock 30
rock you Motown it never get into nudes
yes sure yeah he's a funny guy man yeah
I'm not a new guy now but I'll tell you
what I think double livegonzo is one of
the best records ever made for just you
have to have that straight [ __ ] where
I just want that record gah you know
it's so insane and he's got the balls to
play a bird lay a Berlin yeah I can't
even play like a high akin it's like a
jazz guitar he's huge plays it because
jim mccarty played one in the Detroit
wheels I was so weird because no one
played one and then it's blond so it
looks even more like he's gonna play
jazz like you know and then he just
comes out and he just plays like
stranglehold and you lose your mind yeah
he's a maniac he really is a man you
still one of the greats you know so you
know that there's so much to go back and
listen to guitar playing wise yeah
always you know when you talk about
Eddie Van Halen that's it that's how you
that's a innovator because I think he's
the number one yeah I think for me of
all time
because of what he did you know some
people push it forward and ya did ya
know I mean there were a lot of there's
a lot I have a lot of friends in la that
Steve Lukather these are great players
yeah and it's all in that period when
the LA guys had chops yeah yeah yeah
well there's that scene it's kind of
like after Steely Dan where all these
guys were around that were really killer
players you know it's kind of like that
baked potato seen yeah but then they had
to make music at it yeah exactly um of
them did ya like halls words and all
thats that you know all those well you
know that's like well you know again if
it doesn't have like a leer no songs
that's I'm saying riff yeah you know I I
think it's important yeah yeah what now
you worked with Donald Fagen man and I
am an absolute huge Steely Dan fan yeah
yeah like I [ __ ] I never saw him and
I think a 96 they finally tour I go see
him at the conquer pavilion and I lose
my mind because every song sounded exact
to the record well that's because they
but that's because all that care was put
into those records yeah I'm gonna waste
it and change it yeah no no the everyone
playing in that current band is it's a
fan of the records Catherine saying you
know just saw him twice as [ __ ] ah let's
see I had a band up on the Upper East
Side playing its joint Hades and I was
like 91 I guess 90 91 and my keyboard
player jeff young who's now with jackson
browne yeah I had to get bored players
and Harvey Brooks played bass from
supersession right yeah yeah I had like
a nine-piece band you know up there
called a little big band and Jeff said
hey uh Fagan's coming down sick what get
out of here yeah well you are we talking
like a 90 right 90 wow so so there's no
Steely Dan he's just a ghost he's just
days I guess nine fly was out and the
other one was coming out maybe he was
working on karmic here yet or something
humble you know or yeah anyway I can't
remember everything but some of it that
the place was empty and he was sitting
on a corner by himself at a table and
Jeff calls offices come on up come on
and play man he says yeah all right he
brings this melodica he's got them yeah
that thing he plays a lot of it like a
saxophone player yeah and I said we'll
let you want to sing something and you
know we're like figuring he goes yeah
down along the cove well I'm Dylan here
Wow something something from John Wesley
Hardin yeah yeah yeah so he doesn't know
it nobody quickly just writes out a
chord chart and hands it to us girls go
Wow and he was for him I I and I'm not
really speaking for him but in my
opinion is that for him to be in such a
free situation was fun right you know
because he didn't have a lot of that in
you know in the past yes really damn
sure its superstructure super structured
but I think and then he started coming
around more and more and then we put a
band together you know we put those rock
and soul revue together Wow and started
to in New York nights and rock and soul
revue at that Lone Star just and that's
where I met a lot of people and he would
you know he was really gracious we
started learning some state little by
little we're just like pushing saying
what if we do I don't know maybe you
know yeah if we do yeah how about that
okay how about Chain Lightning okay yeah
what about green earrings okay you know
what about reeling in the years no
hahaha it was like I remember getting in
a cat coming out of a cab and and insane
why can't we do wheeling in the years
ahead well why can't I just go home put
on my bell bottoms and platform shoes
and look at myself in the mirror wow
that's my I love that song and I took a
friend to say hits you see what it is
out guys that with their hits yeah they
sort of someone that deep yeah and that
much of a genius yeah they don't want it
you know the hits almost it's to them
it's like I want to do something that's
not the hits yeah my buddy hates that
song cuz he thinks it's Skynyrd you know
no it's very different I know yeah
totally i'm like met this thing is just
cocaine driving music you know it's like
but happen now but and that's a
compliment to Skynyrd oh yeah abandon
you who don't need compliments cuz
they're great too unbelievable but it's
wrong so yeah yes yeah yes you're wrong
yeah me wrong anyway Fagan was really
cool and we were doing stuff and and
I rick danko would come and how Gary
Busey would come Gary please Rick would
bring get carry with him yeah yeah well
what account it's like playing football
on stage with Gary Busey I tell you fun
yeah and you know and and uh Mac
Rebennack and just you know all the
whole the usual New York's us rice right
we're coming up and Donald was bringing
around Paul Griffin the great keyboard
player and and bringing around we just
bring around old singers and people that
Phoebe Snow became part of the truth
Michael McDonald and everybody yeah and
and then one one day we're playing the
Lone Star me with my big mouth of course
I see Walter and he's like us walking
like the wall he's like we're playing
yeah just he's just like you know he's
got the hoodie on his head he's like the
Unabomber Bob yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sunglasses and and he's just kind of
walking the wall DC night then I called
him out like from the states Wow Becker
get up here I made him get up here he
hasn't forgiven me but we're really
tight now yeah yeah funny way yeah I
don't think he's ever forgiven me for
that but he did come up and uh and the
two-headed monster and sued to uh who to
come back together why and he gave him
my strat to play and he and I think I'm
pretty sure we played black friday wow
wow and he's a Grimm monster guitar
player yeah I'm bass player yeah and
songwriter he's got shitloads of guitars
I just saw him he played a Kareem of
thee and the Korean explore yeah I
[ __ ] loved him for that you know out
of coach Schellas i'll share these kids
i got a corona me yes so we all the time
talk gear and stuff yeah he's become a
really really really good cat you know
with me yeah and i know that you know
there's we all have so much admiration
for those guys yeah that it's hard to
separate it from the human being you
know right i been gonna be that guy yeah
i know i always china wall starts going
up it really does man it's funny because
sometimes I'll hold it back as much as I
can yeah well no no what happens because
it just does uh it just does because
their minds are different yep you know
they're like uh-oh here comes the
superphone that's what happened I see
the bricks actually going up yeah
yeah you'd stop it somehow yeah I really
can once it starts going yeah it's Jeff
you know chair but it's okay I i found
that um with artists that you admire
it's best to just be yourself and that's
it and let them and and and talk about
old blues guys yea yea networks every
time or equipment any i'm going to talk
equipment anything but their music yeah
yeah yeah yeah you become that chris
farley bit with paul mccartney you just
become that guy yeah yeah you know I'm
really careful on I get it about
ninety-eight percent of the time I'm
pretty good but if it was like a Zach de
la Rocha from rain yeah you know guys
that just really blew my mind like a
karen o from jas where i would just be
like what the [ __ ] i mean like the
amount of like next level that they are
you know well you but that's for you too
yeah you told us for you no they don't
and it's funny too because some people
are you'd think they're not shy but they
are shy oh yeah they are sure they don't
it's uncomfortable ya hear about how
great they are coming yeah buddy when
somebody tells me like oh you're really
funny you like I can't believe how great
I I do feel weird you know because I'm
like I'm so new usually you're like this
too yeah that was my worst [ __ ] night
yeah right i thinks i was funny yeah
well i always think like dude this bill
burr and ck and chip a let's take it out
of me there's no way yeah i mean so i
get it you know well those three guys
who just mentioned are the Mount Everest
oh that's right Rushmore the Rushmore of
a mountain and I neveress both yeah
actually mount rushmore on Mount ever
that's right that's right that's how I
oh hi up Dale yeah I mean I hang with a
lot of big comedians but when i do cck
well Louie was on our show for years he
was alright was amazing so I know I'm a
different way yeah like to me yeah I
really think he's the Zeppelin a comedy
so I really trip out around I'm like oh
hey Louie and I just crew you know I
just I just get away yes that he's just
uh you know I'm proud of them okay a big
brother I
from like the night early nineteen guy's
a [ __ ] artists you know and um let's
dive to I you see Dave on the [ __ ]
train yeah Chappelle where you going you
know it's adds something I got to go
down and I could go up to catch a rising
star do the show or something you know
let's talk about the show you're playing
around New York and you get a call to be
in the conan band yeah is this the
beginning of conan yeah the very
beginning because you know all of us
jersey guys know each other well Max and
I know each other from Bruce and other
situations yeah and I was working with
Clarence at the time in living in
Sausalito at his house Wow up there I
hit a call from man you're living in
Sausalito at in Clarence's house right
mansion we could live we could never run
into each other Wow and just up there we
have a band and we're working saw
salinas beautiful are you hanging at the
plan or anything what do you guys doing
we go down to uh what's it called a
sweet water I love the sweet water man
Mill Valley yeah I played so many gigs
there how about that dress rehearsal eat
with the other sweetwater that was in
Sausalito oh I don't even know that
memory never did you ever play the mill
valley one yes I did I love the
downstairs the discus with elvin bishop
and uh and charlie musselwhite Wow
charlie musselwhite one of the best
harmonica players ever oh maria muldaur
was that gary goldberg that place had
[ __ ] history but anyway yeah so
anyway so and Mack says to me I got an
audition with this guy who's gonna take
over for Letterman don't tell Clarence
oh yeah yeah because if Clara you tell
Clarence he's gonna steal the gig yeah
all Clarence's to do is drop a diamond
he's got a gig was her personality is so
you yeah you know yeah and I know him
and we're good friends so I don't say
anything you know on Matt Glantz is
mind-boggling he was and he was a force
of nature I couldn't believe him man I
saw knew it you know uh he was a natural
like a like a natural just uh you know
uh he didn't really know what music was
but he was music that's great imagining
like he could he read me no no no he
didn't know what a note was oh no he's
just the most natural it was just like
natural Wow I mean it would be you know
I don't know what to be like being great
not being able to even read the script
yeah yeah yeah yeah but so what Wow go
an unbelievable just go look here's that
you know he'd be like great for four
that's why he was a such a talent on
stage yeah there was nothing blocking
you know no thought blocking yeah the
heart to the hand music there's no rules
yeah the music goes from the heart right
into the horn I'm going well the heads
not part of it Wow so uh he was just a
wonderful person yeah and we were really
you know really good friends at that
time and uh and I didn't tell him yeah I
got to go back to New York yeah it's um
max he's can audition and and they say
do you know a guitar playing on the mac
says to me though guy I don't have a
band you know huh so I said well I have
my vivino brothers band yeah Jerry and
Scott Healy and Mike meriden well James
one worth can't do the gay cuz you're
playing drums yeah since then they said
all right and and let's get some more
horns let's get la Bamba and pender out
of the Jukes yeah so we grabbed them
because they had all played with Bruce
right so we kind of put a band together
together you know as partners and we
were partners for a long time right
until he was just doing Bruce too much
right and then when we came out here and
the [ __ ] hit the fan you know and I I
really can't say you know I don't want
to say anything negative about what
happened because we're in a good
position now right so I don't want to
appear bitter about what happened with
us at NBC just was a bad circumstance
well it could be one of the most [ __ ]
insane Jones Act we were 16 years up to
do this and then you know a guy decides
to double back and go back on his word
and the network decides to go for it
yeah so it's really not one person's
fault nope it's not but it is one of the
most craziest things ever to happen it's
an a I changed my mind yep also and and
it's a network having cold feet about us
yeah oh no confidence no confidence and
then also when we did get there trying
to change the thing that's we're sitting
here with these microphones in your
house doing this so freely yeah and
that's the kind of exchange that we'd
like to have on our show yet you know
when you're there at the ad corporate
NBC headquarters or CBS or ABC any
where you are wherever you are in a
corporate and you're on their corporate
lot their lawyers are breathing down
your neck every day I guess it's you
know it's harder to work in a you know
in a real creative situation yeah so
we're in a way better place now right
where I are so I can't really comment on
it other than that everything that
happens gets you to where you are today
yeah and I wouldn't be sitting on this
couch with you so [ __ ] it man yeah yeah
see look look what that didier day
before over here man how I'm on your
podcast looking at this [ __ ] weird
masks that's a devo bougie boy yeah yeah
what I wanted to ask is over the years I
had gone to the tonight show many many
times it was Bradford Marsalis yeah and
I remember specifically watching exactly
what went down Bradford pulled in the
band people walked in they tuned up for
about five minutes stuttering john did a
warm-up they played one hour he got in
his car and he laughs and I thought that
could be the ultimate job except that
i'm there at 9am writing is that right
stuff together and our comedy we're
doing comedy on a daily basis writers
have music they need you know we're
doing all words stop piling all kinds of
q's right well I'm working usually from
nine or 10 at the latest of them later
so it's like a real job it's an eight
hour job for me no [ __ ] I yeah or more
depending on if I stay afterwards and do
stuff why because we love doing it and
my band comes in at noon and they're
done at six so out there for six hours
right you know now um you've been there
since 93 yeah did you like when early
Conan I watched the first year coated
and I'm like you know you're like we say
this ain't gonna last hanging by a
thread right I'm like this isn't gonna
last game over you're like who is this
guy's got you know he's giant tall but
then eventually all of a sudden
something turns and I go this is the
[ __ ] man well because you know and
that's probably partially the genius of
Lorne Michaels right recognizing that
yeah I'm sticking with it yep you know
and and he's done that it's just my
opinion now with Saturday Night Live
cast
I've gone in and he sticks with them and
I watch and I start to get it yeah you
know there's a lot of people that would
say oh it ended with Bill Maher the
wrong yeah they're all there on
everybody has any generation has people
they like better yeah so you know now
the Adam Sandler's are the old-timers
yeah yeah these guys that came along you
know now even bill hader's becoming like
a no that's an old-timer of Saturday
Night Live yes new guys yeah yeah and um
it's the greatest farm system for
comment it really is no and I think to
his credit the only time the show wasn't
good was when dick ever saw was
producing it yeah yeah exactly exactly
yeah came back that's such a weird air
all right yeah yeah he's like I gotta
fix this right yeah what happens with
baseball teams too yeah I remember
though I mean when I really look at
Conan it's some of the most legendary
funny comedy of my time late night
because I would come home from playing
gigs always in the city I get home right
around that time I turn it on and some
of this [ __ ] like that that I still
think that the triumph the insult dog is
probably one of the top five funny
things I've ever seen in my life ever
smuggles a genius two men unbelievable
you know who's you know and these cats
like you know that we're with us and now
we're making stuff for 4 from Comedy
Central and for adult swim yeah a lot of
our X writers are doing these fantastic
things you know yeah acha lips oh yeah
yeah I'm friends with Brendan small and
rather Greg feels great and we do that
show that bake show Dino was there
originally and then Dino did moral orel
and uh yeah I mean there's there's some
real you know the great thing about that
don't swim yeah that it has no
boundaries no rules there's no rules
yeah no guidelines yeah you can't go low
enough there yeah and nobody nobody will
say don't we can't put that here yeah
yeah right its I like it you know and I
like that the freedom that that has man
and comedy central's get all these cable
stations yep you know that even FX saw
this coming yeah FX yeah nobody saw this
coming now that all the good shits being
produced on cable now now TV s seems
be good for you guys they're right good
man and and if only our unions had made
better tails yeah we label oh yeah well
you know it happened with music it's you
know it's after a while though it sounds
like sour grapes when you say it used to
be better in the old days yeah this is
what it is now it is yeah you know the
landscape is changing incredibly fast
it's crazy man I got a team Netflix my
TV's got that [ __ ] built into it yeah
yeah hello Annette flick that TV hasn't
been on in five years right there
because I just watch everything on the
computer yeah you know that's right yeah
stream it and now what I do yeah it's uh
I by TV shows seems yeah that's it cuz i
watch them on the plane and they'll
never have good enough why this is why
they'll never have good enough my theory
yes Pyrrha see why they will never have
good enough Wi-Fi on the planes because
then we can get all we could stream all
that [ __ ] for free yeah so exactly we
gotta buy stuff yeah actually download
it to watch it on the plane bad flights
and and work and everything like well
stop buying the movie on the plane mr.
charge it too much for oh yeah already
edited and crappy anyway it's horrible
yeah horrible so I don't care then I'll
buy a whole season of American Horror
Story or sons of happy whatever and I'll
watch it on the plane hell yeah and I
don't care if it costs to be 20 bucks
you know now it's still a better 20
bucks than I could I could buy like a
bad meal for you absolutely or thirty
bucks you know have either up to 33
dollars it's like [ __ ] twenty dollars
is to eat I get fast food burgers in a
shake what was that first season like
when your ad Conan you like you're
working on a TV show and every day I
mean every day like something would
change about the set yeah something
would change about the the opening
something would change about where the
band was something they was like the
committee was down you know yeah all the
people from upstairs at 8h which was
Saturday Night Live yeah yeah they would
all come down to consult and they were
like doctors standing around a dying
patient yeah yeah hmm a lot of beard
stroking what if we try this
you know we're just trying anything
right I think um Conan is one of the
smartest people I ever met in my life
yeah and funniest and genuine real good
guy and a great music fan and a good
musician himself you know oh yeah so he
so when I think there was a point where
he finally took control of his own show
yeah after all those onion the
communicators own confidence yeah and
that takes a while sometimes when you
get shoehorned into this position yeah
you know you're writing on simpson you
got a phone call it says you're on kid
isn't that crazy you're writing on the
simpsons and next thing you know you're
taking over for Letterman yeah yeah and
you you know and if you look at his
history when he was a kid he even has
like there's even like eight millimeter
you know or videos of him you know doing
his the talk show in the yard with his
kid with his sisters and brothers ya
know with a microphone yeah just like
being Johnny Carson right so to me it's
like me playing along with my Al Kooper
records you know my Mike bloomfield
you're just getting ready the same thing
yeah we were and and now we're realizing
what we what we thought we could
possibly achieve and um yes luck is a
big part of it there's a lot of talent
out there yeah but it's also um you know
I try to tell kids when they hey well
you know they come in they can play
their asses off they come out of
Berkeley and then all of his [ __ ]
together I said you know a baseball
player hits the ball and he doesn't drop
down and start doing pushups he plays
the game yeah you gotta learn how to
play the game you have learned any work
a show big well I always I always say
the heart of your work the lucky you yet
yeah that's right that's true and also
story man it's also the relationships
you forge with people you know and and
and and that's right connections right
time report early time connection so it
goes all the way back to being Jersey
yeah and being followed people we did I
way up that's right well you know but
before that I was already on the road
with you know with Felix Cavaliere from
the rascals and and Laura Nero and and
with John Sebastian I was already
working before I even met him yes
already doing a Broadway show yeah I was
already playing guitar
are in you know in studios so we were on
different paths at the same time you
know yeah we would run into people from
Jersey we knew and I got that one phone
call they happen to be available that
one leave me if I didn't get that phone
call yeah what else got it somebody else
will be doing that gig yeah I don't know
that it would be the same you can't
always say if but may I right you know
just happened that way and I'm grateful
for it i'm fortunate you know i'm glad
that it's lasted this long yep and i
think it can last a long time because we
love all of us love doing it ya know we
don't get we don't pull up at at 10
minutes 24 and get in our car at six
o'clock and go home yeah I don't tell
you guys loving that I was there I gotta
come over oh I've got many times I've
ever seen you there i'm going to tell
you a funny story i love going to kona
because i keep going going like
eventually I'm going to be on Conan so I
want to keep going so when I go there
there's no mystery it'll be like second
hat to me well then you know I
somebody's got to go see you yeah oh
yeah JP I talk yeah we're getting it
together but my thing is I like to do
that so when I finally get on it it's
second nature I know but there's a ago
I've gone a few times with Ian as we get
on and show your motorcycle yeah my gosh
this is able to show my accident you
know yeah this is a great story though
about eight months ago I was standing
next to the band and Ian Edwards was
doing stand-up and I never forgot it he
did the Martin Luther King joke the the
guy that assassin it and he says
remember he says I know that Jesse
Jackson is doesn't mean anything because
the assassinator had a perfect shot at
him and just put his gun away just then
shoot him I watched your whole band
explode into laughter and I was dying
because that nervous left yeah you guys
are that asaru and also I couldn't
believe the joke was going off like oh
my god they approved this way yeah you
know and I watched it all you guys and
you guys were dying well you know that
certain amount of shock is needed in
comedy
yeah yeah no it can't be you know it
can't be you know safe yeah like a
lobotomized yeah boring safe comedy yeah
that's what I love about cone and they
let that they let it get edgy you know
it has to um it has to but in in a suit
yea tall you know we're wearing suits
yeah that's the funny thing you know I
don't wear a [ __ ] sue yeah yeah
that's a character i play on TV yeah and
people see me those where's your suit
man oh yeah alright so sitting in my
dressing room yeah it's at work it's
that work where that's my uniform it uh
let's before I cut you loose here let's
talk a little gear your yeah I saw you
Ray Manzarek rosanna last week oh no I
mean Robby Krieger sorry and you have
our SGA address geez SG being one of my
favorite but do you have a pelham blue
SG like Jackie's yeah I saw you I ever
mind has a mind has a the other style
has a big Speed Force shoe vibrato oh
yeah keys got I took the old thing off
it was no good right I couldn't deal
with it right how many guitars you got
less than I used to yeah hahahaha I
swear to God I just unloaded another 9
because if I don't play if I look at a
guitar go I haven't played that in five
years let's get rid of it yeah where do
you got nobody else should know I don't
go to norm I have a friend in jersey
that does it for me Wow because because
norm if I paid a lot of money for a
guitar from mom he's not gonna give me a
lot of money back yeah yeah you know
what he does he had business to be in oh
but he does now you know I be anything
the best they keep going up you know
norm is if you want a piece there's no
one better norm is like Sotheby's
there's no one's gonna get the real crap
there is no [ __ ] with norm stuff
yeah no issues as we said that's right
yeah you know no is no yet no change
tuners yes well uh change if there are
normal tell you yeah yeah
and there and there and they're great
they're what store but Marcus man you
see man those cats are unbelievable I've
been going there for 15 20 years you
know yeah what's your best guitar you
got a 59 power 58 or my favorite is my
53 believe it or not 53 3 wraparound
tailpiece 2p 90s and all you have to
have a special no it's a it's a standard
others like Freddie Kings you know with
53 and fifty end of 53 they put that
wrap around right yeah it took that
trapeze thing of course yeah oh the gold
talk gold top yeah i got i know it is
sick i had 54 i love it you know 90s rap
rap unbelievable 9 I have a red 59
custom three pick up custom with two
double whites in it Wow the Middle's of
black not no AF sticker red 15 I like
refinish this red I don't know yeah
right they were flat bread once made
really yeah no it's red Wow might have
been Rihanna off with factory reef in
maybe you know you got any kind you know
I used to but not the real ones yeah I
had some reissues you know I'm not a I'm
not a collector yeah I'm a player yeah
um my les paul am I 59 tele is like my
favorite male a board yeah unbelievable
kite on my favorite guitar I've 59-60
the the the logos on the I mean the
serial numbers on the bottom yep also
it's a wider fretboard that's a wider
fretwork in a row so who r a Pullman
from the Wrecking Crew Wow and it's on
out of limits by the markets no [ __ ]
yeah what uh when that's my favorite
what about amps um I since I got to
California yeah I acquired a black face
uh deluxe pro over oh yeah a black face
twin reverb 6 both 60 super loud at face
a black face 210 vibrolux yeah great and
for yeah I think that's the best they
recovered 59 baseman Wow we covered in
black toe box that says crazy horse
number seven Reese I what ya know tweet
on that uh it's one of them one of the
crazy horse amps that's crazy yeah well
they used to do them yeah I think maybe
it I
I like to believe it was Danny Witten's
amp oh my god I tonight's the night just
me saying it's Danny's and it's not
nails because it was Neal's he would
know yeah anyways I'll have yeah yeah
Wow could have been Nils is even when he
was playing with yeah you played on that
part could have been the one that they
use for Spooner use for oh yeah yeah I
never know what it was or just was one
of the rehearsal lamps yeah anyway that
amp is fantastic you know and then then
now the new magnet own I have the
twilighters yeah they lent me oh yeah
that's saw that thing yeah great and i
have a new hand wired orange oh that's a
great this is this is a new thing now
yeah they started going to point when
why your arches yeah this is a combo we
also make it in a head yeah i saw the
combo I was like a ramp show it's over i
have that and the twilight are going now
at the same time what and and how do you
guys see you you got the [ __ ] in front
of the cases in front of the drummers
and stuff like that like for volume no
we just play loud he's play that last oh
yeah we do we like and i also have like
a couple of those new ec fenders your
fires yeah yeah twin Oh Lux's I have two
of those Wow because they were so good I
liked him so much I said I better get
two of these because they're gonna be
gone yeah that's how they are yeah
they're gonna be gone bandar eight years
ago made us point-to-point maps yeah
those that in those little printer
tremor locks member those how about
those hot rod print asusto that were
like I seem a true tone music they were
yeah like I got like a they were like
sea foam green I love that substance
they make them and then they're gone you
know yeah I think matchless started all
off back then you know because I had
natural some bad cat and bad get well
then mark Sampson that bad cat Cesar
Diaz made me am tonight wow I have a
basement that Cesar modifieds wow you
know and I tried everything and anything
yeah boxes uh oh I love the AC 15 yeah I
have 10 12 of those 1080 oh great amp
I have a hand in here for fab faux I use
a hand wired ac30 ya head in bed and
bottom you know and and that's there's
another 30 guitars there you know with
them mine fab faux so you guys play how
much do you guys play oh I don't know
maybe we do 20 30 days a year you know
well now is not the Letterman show's
over so when we started it well and I
lived in the same building walk on
eighth Street in Mercer a wills in the
bed yeah and we'll would come home and
and I beyond we bind the elevator
together and he would say hey let's
start a beetle band then the door would
open it and I would get off on my floor
and he would go three more floors I was
on like 27 he was on like you know 30 so
right and uh I say yeah sure I see you
yeah every day yeah when we gonna start
that beetle Bennett said get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah why yeah I would leave
finally he says come up to my apartment
and there's four you know three other
guys in him four of them are up there
and he says okay so we're starting I
said why are you kidding yeah these are
the guys I said okay he said well let's
see we can sing I said I'll tell you
what if we can put because together yeah
from Abbey Road he said okay well who
plays and I said well I'll give me the
music and I'll play the harpsichord part
and then Frank we know one of the other
guitar players was dishing out vocal
part he was a vocal genius yeah like
Brian Wilson you know just we dishing
out parts to each guy crazy and then we
learned him and we sang it we worked all
night on it and we got it and we said
that's it we have a band why do that we
know we can rock and we know we can all
play totally if don't sing then we got
do it because this is what it takes you
know they were the great vocal band
unbelievable so that's been going on 17
years Wow yeah septa and what errors do
my three times longer than they were
together holy [ __ ] we're short of doing
three songs so a whole catalog really
yeah holy small yeah yeah it's pretty
it's pretty it's a it's a pretty
impressive body of work to be able to
draw from and
and we've I've learned so much about
recording engineering you know singing
playing arranging now going head into
those records yeah there is not a better
a better band that that changed music
religion fashion philosophy use of drugs
yeah uh just everything um about the
world yeah yeah that band while they
were very anyone that denies it and says
they don't like the Beatles yeah is as
Howlin wolf said you wrong well it's
funny because i'm not a big Beatles man
right yeah Marc Maron you're wrong okay
well i'm not a big Beatles guy either
but like let's say there's stuff you
like them oh yeah there's no way I would
be like yeah but men a couple weeks ago
at the Chateau Marmont they've got a
turntable there and there was a beer out
here so I'm DJing for the would come
together comes on you're like oh well
that's going record one you like holy
smokes man I don't have to like
everything to be she ate it exactly i
just like the drug era when we started
right the point was and and we all we
all agreed on this one point we will
play we will start playing the music
they never played live that's great we
started at at rubber sole yeah forward
oh that's great and learned everything
that they never played and that would
that being a big once we have
accomplished that we said okay now we're
gonna go backwards and we started having
fun yeah realizing that there was just
as much put into the first record that's
the last record yeah considered the
times they were made yeah yeah some
really really fine George Martin was the
fifth Beatle that's incredible that guy
right i mean i mean you're really
looking at revolutionising recording
bands all the [ __ ] they did we're
talking about for track and everything
add to do that we have to work with
geoff emerick we recorded for a college
a college recording class they came up
and we recorded i'm cha we recorded and
your bird can sing Wow and one other one
which I oh hey bulldog those two Wow
with geoff emerick at the board you know
showing that show in the class yeah yeah
the use of the compressors in the use of
that's crazy and and you
when he would keep coming out Jeff
saying Ringo hit he would say to rich
play the kick drum harder Ringo had the
hardest heaviest foot ever Wow studio no
[ __ ] huh yeah yeah and and you know when
you really think about it they were a
band people always try to pull them
apart you can't take each guy out of a
band and say I love when they say that
like angry ghost okay yeah right wasn't
a great guitar yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
George was a god he was a great guitar
ball was a great guitar oh yes John you
know yeah and and and you know they
revolutionized the [ __ ] along with the
beach boys down that same you know that
same path and different roads you know
sort of checking each other out
constantly I think there was a Brian
will competition Courtney comp
composition yeah I was held songwriting
was [ __ ] next level yeah like you
know I just saw recently the Beach Boys
film you know oh yeah don't want to see
that man and you know you just
immediately go crazy over Pet Sounds you
know like those [ __ ] songs are so
darken and badass and it's so so much
depth and layers I wasn't made for these
times that's like that's just crazy man
well all of that yeah dude I'm glad I
had you on man it's such a I could try I
love you because we could talk music for
[ __ ] hour man I hope nobody's bored
with us no no people love love music
talk you know but you know it's great
that um that I know how many you know I
just put a picture up without my harmony
you know yeah rocket yep and I got like
180 hits on it right away on Instagram I
said oh people like this [ __ ] they did
would like to see guitar they love to
see me guitar players like to oh yeah I
love guitars more than anything man
because they to me represent the
ultimate rock and roll tool yeah its
ground zero the 59 Les Paul to me
destroys me it hurts me so [ __ ] bad
and also a 52 esquire butterscotch one
pick up rock and roll me yeah well
that's you know that's why my junior is
a downer I'm like that's just pee
nineties the way
can work a volume out on the town on
seven yet and then roll it out cleaner
funky clean unbelievable man guitars are
amazing yeah and you know what the best
guitar is really yeah the one you don't
have that's all is it yeah you know I
nice i want that one all my friends used
to clown because i'd get a new one every
five months and they go let me guess
best guitar ever huh well no cuz i dont
yeah for now and some people do that
with girlfriend Yeah Yeah Yeah right I
feel guitars I truly could feel this and
this is how weird i am i would go into a
guitar store i'd pick a guitar off and i
play a few different ones and also in a
song would come out of when i go this is
the one and i would buy it and in like
five six maybe 10 20 songs would come
out of it and then the songs done has
done and I swear and there'd be like
okay red violin hey Brett they brought
me they brought me the songs thank you
ma'am but there's there's something to
that ice why because when I went when a
songwriter it's rudimentary p.m. has
piano chops and sits down to piano ya
like like a John Lennon or Neil Young
they're not great piano yeah yeah but
they write the greatest song on the
piano they do it was it sparse yeah
really get into melody of the villain
wrote so many things on p.m. absolutely
absolutely a lot of songs you hear the
demos are on piano you go oh yeah yeah
yeah what's your Instagram uh Jimmy v
music okay and then you got a Twitter
same thing at Jimmy be music and then of
course when's the beatles thing in oh
yeah we're playing nada cal state
northridge on this is a funny show too
because it's not normal for us on the
seventeenth of october we're playing the
in one set we're playing the Hollywood
Bowl and Dodger Stadium show whoa yeah
that all the songs now we're not doing
the show I get us going oh and by the
way who totally to be here another
oh that [ __ ] when the songs yeah the
way they the way we play them yeah which
is which is B don't like ya ya know like
you without the screaming what guitar
you playing the beetle ban which guitars
uh which guy which guitars what song
time oh I'm just wondering because he
played strat mostly I never to strats
one sonic blue and one painted role of a
sonic I have a red Lucy Les Paul with
the same everything yeah I have a 57 duo
jet like George's Wow a organist and no
no it's black oh it's black Tennessean
and iconic country gin Wow a futurama
which he played in which he played in
Hamburg yeah I have a Rickenbacker 325 I
have a Rickenbacker 12 whatever the era
is you get it well that is doe Texan yan
j16 te epiphone Texan yeah and to
epiphone casinos Oh casinos great right
yeah one like Paul's with the paddle
headstock and and uh with a big ass and
then one a blonde one like like I've got
the blond elitist journal and yawns oh
not just whenever you know what and an
SG of course yeah yeah and thought that
one SG like like George's and um and uh
that may be in a nylon string which I
need for certain things Wow and to sit
ours wow you've been sitting a Ricky ram
and like George had yeah I found one
just like his and then another one that
I got in New York and I have a third one
I keep at work at Conan because you
gotta stay sharp on it if you got it you
got to pick it up now yeah yeah yeah
yeah you just play all you know well you
know when will Lee who's like just to me
that one of the greatest musicians in
the world yeah says if I can play bass
on paperback rider and sing it and you
can play sitar don't get it and I did I
got it I said [ __ ] I'm gonna learn to do
this one of those guys doing now like
Anton fig and will I entonce touring
with Bonamassa because he plays on all
the real wow wow
no that's right away he's into a will
started the minute we'll got out now he
he he took every giggy's been turning
down for 30 years yeah we're working
more than ever Wow made it started work
on an alicia keys album right away you
know it's always in the studio now he
just was out here at Monterey Jazz
Festival he's over in Europe and Japan
shed and back here that's a man is
probably gonna live out here for the
winter you know yeah yeah yeah would you
like that way a lot I love LA that's
great right you're in I still have a
Brooklyn Dodgers hat on yeah yeah that's
all you're in elk in New York your whole
life you've been here six years wit what
neighborhood yen um I'm in uh to Toluca
Lake bourbon yeah that's quarter so I
can be nice to the studio from work
that's great but I come up here and I
drive up here to your place and I go oh
[ __ ] I don't know how to live but if I
but how do you how do you have a drink
and drive home here I I over yeah yeah
it's like four bucks or someone be in
here and get use to it yeah you did but
people are so nice like a guy pulls over
as I'm coming up on ya so I don't know
how to do that yeah it's really not room
for two cars it's not man it's crazy and
this is wider than Laurel Canyon those
streets like Kirkwood and [ __ ] that's
under IVA bowl I know it isn't it but
you're not far from the sign right now
I'm Constance is right behind us I like
it though when I come up into these
little Hill places I say this is good
but I since my I have like a really low
standard of living from having in New
York like anything's good yeah so the
things I needed where I live are there
yeah a 24-hour vons again walk to ya
cleaners Dana drugs a Japanese
restaurant and a French restaurant
italian restaurant sardos which has
TARDIS yeah yeah yeahs used to have porn
star karaoke but they don't do that i
don't know i think they do it to says
yeah they used to do comedy is such a
whole it's growl right it's a real
justice stink pit you go to that 24-hour
dry cleaner there in the corner oh yeah
those guys Milton Eddie yeah guys are up
long night ed or is it Milton edge like
have you murdered someone in need you
know what I do you know why they're open
all night because the studios are yeah
that's rough over there that's right
that's crazy and that what i use flare
which is right by me and then and then
there's a starbucks yeah that we used to
be a blockbuster but there's no more
videos yeah
I'm gonna come over and hang with you at
the conan yeah yeah come over come over
in a couple weeks yeah yeah yeah yeah
take your bike you don't have a bike now
yeah it's like renew what was it a 92
FXR Harley he was cherry his dream by
glad you don't have a rice burner ma'am
oh no I never did that [ __ ] you know I
never got into that power I was just
more into just [ __ ] you know but when
i lived on eighth street though there
were those you know those racing bikes
yeah yeah yeah they go and they will go
up 30 floors at me loud as hell I mean
to be ten guys yeah down eighth Street
you know with chicks on the back with
her butts hanging out and was a big
thing in New York hell yeah oh yeah when
he moves like that hip hop arrow out
bikers yeah yeah yeah hey Louie road and
he got [ __ ] hit man I heard him talk
about like I guess in the 90s or
whatever maybe 80s he got [ __ ] in New
York yeah impossible to ride it yeah
that's uh it's so great that's why I
always said oh I could never live in New
York cuz I i'm addicted to riding and
now i'm like oh maybe i could live in
New York you know they yeah it's it's
not a good place to ride it's not a good
place to ride a bison own at all it's
[ __ ] rude or dangerous man here it's
cool and I have a lot of friends that
ride you know i don't i'm too old to
start now on my hands yeah yeah yeah i
see you falling you put that horrible
picture up yeah i did that for you I
knew you wanted to see solid oh you know
you get that feeling down here yeah I
know in your balls yeah thanks I love
words you're you're great man ah and
I'll have you back on we come back
rather well going well pick some era of
music and will [ __ ] talk the [ __ ] out
yeah we should just take right we should
play records while we talk yeah yeah
let's do that whether they sound good or
not yeah yeah yeah in the background
where I've been maybe that it'll be like
a mystery science theater yeah there you
go alright man thanks for coming by
there you guys go yeah
you